the signature cigar fedora and shades it
could only be one man we caught up with
Udo Lindenberg during rehearsals for his
new tour which kicks off this weekend
this is um to uh it's a big adventure
dunford giant or the biggest production
in the world a real rock show with
aerial acrobatics buttock it's real big
bigger stones you know and Sonja a huge
sound system you know even louder than
ACDC who says rock stars have to be
modest this new series of gigs completes
a trilogy of tours that began in 2014
Germany's elder statesman of rock just
turned 70 and he still likes to play the
rebel he's a sweet cat is a stray cat
you know yeah he's a flexible man you
know he does he loved things to me
they're singing it is dancing lindenberg
lives can be a memorable occasion in
1983 he performed in East Germany even
if only briefly to an audience
handpicked by the communist authorities
it was accompanied on the 1997 bel canto
tour by major film orchestra
in 2011 he was featured on the MTV
Unplugged series including a duet with
former neue deutsche welle star and nowt
swayamvaram singer in a goomba
2012 saw Linda barracks first stadium
tour after a lengthy struggle with
alcoholism starting in the 1990s
Lindenberg bounced back bigger than ever
this is news or bad news it's sublime we
always look forward two tours going on
stage with a band and thumping out songs
vm the burn it's my personal El Dorado
short answer is Montezuma's El Dorado
eldorado happens to be the name of a
track on his new album which went
straight to the top of the charts super
good wicked Oh every morning I wake up
with his big grin sometimes I have to
pinch myself as if I'm dreaming I've
been in the business a hundred years and
still get a kick out of it Nichols
affordable goes up kick this year he'll
be crisscrossing Germany till the end of
June in some cities he'll be playing
several dates due to demand
nobody Hilda me only once I'm onstage
the band really lets it rip he's been
dogging the old enough to go the
nightingale spreads its wings the
thermal lift comes in and I fly upwards
and then it's one big party under
necessary party via oceans one
the party is set to spill over Germany's
borders further concerts have planned
for Moscow New York and elsewhere Udo
Lindenberg at 70 as his latest album
says stocka out stateside stronger than
time